what do you think of the pro-fat
movement now it's very interesting the
fat activism
I mean I yeah I've been as people who've
struggled with our weight it's
interesting to see now it's gone the
other way where fat people are like
threatening people on social media 330
pounds and no one should have been
promoting me
I
I was disgusting
and should have been shot I should have
been
hunted down and shot I was not I was a
animal
I should have gotten help someone should
have
someone should have gotten a net and
[ __ ] put me in a cage and help me
so
but there's a movement now well I needed
movement I needed a lot of movement
because I was dying yeah okay there's a
movement to celebrate I should have not
been celebrated and I had I had
rashes yes it's hard smell I mean I was
I was not okay and but what has happened
you know what I mean like what has
happened where
it it's gone to a place
where there is a celebration
of that type of behavior
well I think that no I don't think fat
people should be victimized or treated
like [ __ ] no but no one thinks that of
course not but we've gone to in a such
an extreme place I have a lot of fat
professionals my agent is fat and
they're very distracted they're fat
my tour is booked
if you look at the way my tour is booked
it's booked in towns with steakhouses so
that my agent can come I have a fat
assistant she's lovely but she's
distracted because they're always
thinking about eating I'm surprised your
tour isn't all at like Burger King yeah
no my tour is literally routed around
the openings of steakhouses
and but
you know it is a distracting thing like
I'm trying to lose weight it's hard
do they always have food in their mouths
when you're talking to them they're
chewing they're crunching ladies
will they crunch
they crunch things they have little
vittles that they have they've got food
everywhere like you know it's distract
it's like again it's a compulsion I know
you don't have to tell me I'm an animal
I [ __ ] my face with food I don't even
chew you know what it is I know so to me
the idea that that's become a celebrated
part of our society it's not okay it's
not okay the mukbangs online you've seen
though people just eat people watch I
mean did you see Nick avocados video
where the woman who's getting stabbed
yeah I sent that too please bring that
up someone's getting stabbed there's a
woman in an apartment building getting
stabbed and I don't know if you even
know who this guy is this guy
all he does is eat online and he eats
these crazy things and he's just kind of
killing himself online
every day he's pretty popular and he's
very pop people want to watch him kill
himself with food this is a deeply
Disturbed Society now I want you to
listen to this because this is literally
true someone's getting stabbed to death
in the apartment next door and they
notice it and they keep eating watch
this
all right
okay they taste like this but
no oh you didn't screams Greece here
play it again and I want you to listen
for the screams you can hear them okay
you can literally hear the screams
okay they taste like this but
no oh look I mean there's so many in the
background
you know that he just made me homophobic
and I'm married to a woman yeah yeah
yeah like I want to suck dick after
watching that yeah yeah
it's so disturbing because there's
people millions of them watching this
type of stuff it's it's there's
something that the the internet's
unlocked which is really terribly God
that's so disturbing watching him eat
like that yeah it's really bad
it's I yeah it's not good so he's really
popular he's very popular I've watched a
lot of his stuff he just eats for hours
he goes crazy now why do you watch it
you sick [ __ ] I I don't really know why
when you're really hungry and you want
fast food late at night if you just
watch him eat a bunch of tacos from Jack
In The Box or something uh soothing
about it there's something and it's also
kind of funny and morbid and is he just
talking while he's eating yeah he tell
he has little anecdotes and he has his
boyfriend uh Orlin I think Olin or
Orland
and they do cooking recipes too so
they'll cook ramen noodles with cheese
and eat those and show you recipes and
he'll go around Target and a rascal
scooter and do little skits and stuff
and so this is where we are this is and
they're famous they're famous yeah yeah
and I'm going to do six shows at the
[ __ ] chuckle bunnies yeah
yeah well you know
but this is really disturbing stuff and
your mother is a therapist probably is
she probably is just a very interesting
uh you know thoughts and ideas about how
it got this bad